Atlanta Georgia it is that time who your
main event of evening a best-of-five
match for the prestige of being the
baddest arm wrestler in the world and
for the wal Heavyweight Championship he
introduced into the pit first the
Challenger he says at six feet one inch
tall and weighed in at 327 pounds with a
record of 25 wins and only five losses
known for his incredible power he is one
of the only people who have defeated the
current champion buddy out of rail with
Massachusetts hey
[Applause]
send your dreadlock he's been waiting
for this woman he gonna win over the
moms the last time they met and he feels
like this shot is long long overdue
he's time Jerry and his opponent
standing at 6 feet 3 inches tall running
in at to 168 pounds with a record of 15
wins against only 3 no losses competing
out of Hot Springs Arkansas
he's been unstoppable in the toughest of
the wal classes and had a huge wins in
wal 406 and wal of 503 he has won titles
all over the world and is one bad man he
is the wal heavyweight champion he is
monster
ladies and gentlemen monsters are real
and they live in the world of monster
Michael into the arena with the hammer
it's an opportunity for legitimacy an
opportunity for redemption against the
gingerbread man last time out he lost he
felt buck was are wrong he wants to make
it right
[Music]
this monster is real and he's in the pit
ready to go here trying to win yet
another pair here tonight Neal pick up
and does he look focused oh yeah I word
a look of thunder etched on the face of
monster michael todd by contrast in
current looking Karma's barnwood falls
these two giants to the table will we
see a repeat those epic epic encounter
minutes man 720 last year in Cleveland
we'd like these guys to stay healthy
throughout this time and that's a great
sign because both men yep didn't look
like me we're moving very far there we
go to the straps tie these big boys
together yep strap don't lie seven
minutes and 20 seconds
you can hear the drop in here yeah you
can hear that result it's when you get
you guys at this level I think the the
people in the crowd here can sort of
feel a lot of aura they come to be
occasion look at that we come to yeah
the lady that puts seven ground on it
unconfirmed such a Orthodox arm wrestler
and monocles made his name of late
utilizing the Kings move
[Applause]
anyone see that coming
I know I didn't I didn't either one away
cataract what an unbelievable start from
Jerry cataract Jerry said he came ready
for this one yeah Rob Bridget Jeanie he
meeting to catch Jerry there yeah hell
of a catch the mask boys helping each
other out so cataract for the one
nothing lead thanks to the strap and he
just took care of business look at the
big smile on the face of his wife break
in there and his little boy watching by
contrast the wife of monster Michael
Todd looking like she's just seen a
ghost yeah it was a big one
and he had red hair back to the table
they go not wasting any time these two
men for the hammer nail Jerry cataract
what a huge man this guy does not skip
breakfast so much power sets that leg
against the table we'll find out now if
Michael was that I've been in that first
round wake up
you big drive back to it yeah we'll slip
we'll go to the strap you got more
connection there we didn't run as hard
back he run little more to the side
we'll see it on the replay I think
Michael actually lost some some of the
adhesion on his elbow maybe popped off
the back there but it means nothing
we're gonna get tied together again your
seed on the replay just watch this here
he hits more to the side but he's right
on the elbow was lost there it is oh
this is the pin yeah you know an
overhead of it and that such commitment
from Jerry I mean there is just nowhere
to go
as Michael tried to pronate as he tried
to find a way to put the brakes on Jerry
just shut out the light he made that
much happen in a forum box
strap applied title match Jerry cata at
one-nothing lead on the older Michael
time champions response required yes
latarian go
they drive there from top this time he
gets some purchased elbow is on the pod
firmly starting to apply the wall come
to Jerry ladies and gentlemen we've been
here boys
Mary Katherine is 42 they're brined on
tonight mom this time you can see that
my Gucci lace is very different
he's relaxed he's calm this is all in
the strategy
he's now engaged the kings movies pull
Ned's in hard I'll tell you walk that's
actually more of a defensive role he
hasn't really hits his Kings yet
he's just led back and he's looking to
apply that pressure into Jerry Jerry is
trying to try Michael he's trying to
just make sure that he doesn't energy
until the right time you'll see the
coffee's counting away were around the
52nd about these men are still quickly
realized what we do know about them is
the Hulk man of condition for the wall
game ISIL is gaining ground now man yes
now in a minute and ten
now Michael tried to transition soon
you'll be all for the gap and when he
feels the breath if Jerry lets up the
pressure
Michael jumped behind his arm and he'll
press through for the finish that's what
he's looking for he's climbing and this
is a top roll
there's no Kingsburg there that is gonna
defensive went back up low he's been
training that extensively and he's
watching he's waiting for that bump he's
waiting for the mistake if he feels it
from cataract he will jump behind his
arm and I'll tell you what Michaels put
trying to put the bleed on Jerry
yeah Jerry is working very very hard
here and Michael is not yep little climb
little adjustment Michael working that
angle great look at it there
yeah and he's making sure that he
doesn't get his elbow into a position
where Jerry could expose it that's
better from Terry there's a little bit
of a relaxation there in my pony punish
him for it mycologists real technical
max from Mike
Jerry is just a warrior from a different
quality 15
counting now in this second bowl with
catarata up on nothing it's always the
second round we see this up but I'll
tell you what Michael's feeling the pace
now Michael went from a position if
Jerry breeds Michael will sting it yep a
little stinky boy so look at him testing
supinate him bringing his low apartment
turning his low apartment to Jerry's on
waiting for that little spot it's a
fraction of heartbeat when he feels that
moment he'll immediately transition to
the French himself but Jerry trying to
get it going
walk back off he's just keeping that
pressure applied he is an absolute
warrior over three minutes now ludicrous
length of armwrestling what you call the
longest you ever had that's not what
we're seeing here these got Michael
there with a decision couldn't get it
goes back to that relaxed position again
and Jerry trying to bump down again this
both men now the elasticity is gone yeah
both men are in a really really bad
place
Michael shallow extent and Jerry's
Elmore was so close to coming up they'll
start to lose feeling in their hands and
wrists yeah don't run to go to the
bathroom this much let me tell you
neither man will have any feeling
they're home for days approaching and
we've outrageous more four minutes in
this poor unbelievable career-ending
deathmatch but what they still say is
that Jerry can arrest is fit unhealthy
and he's trying to finish this much and
bring back some painful memories from
Michael Todd yeah
how much endurance us Michael got he
said that his arm would need to break
for him to lose this he did he told us
that this morning we know that Mike's
very smart and calculating we know that
he will try to bleed his opponent in
ways they don't want to be bled but
Jerry Katherine is putting some burner
on the harm we're looking for a pin that
isn't there is not a sign that he's
fatigued well they're so transit earnest
you breathe you get punished
Michael Todd only needs a tiny fraction
of daylight and he'll and run through it
better
let's go on to the sleeveless itsgotime
thing happen again it's not broke with
the tingling there oh boy same thing
that happened to him in Cleveland one
yeah Michael just went over to Rebecca
and said the same thing has happened
again he said it's not broken but the
tingling is there in other words it's
exposed Teri's blowing very very hard
this is you you know what the biggest
factor here is going to be how much did
that take out of these individuals yeah
going for the long game because the
power will drop exponentially now you're
not in a situation where either a man is
gonna feel that the whole top end power
so I'm not really concerned about
Michael having an injury at this stage
let's just watch it again most
importantly without for the fraction of
a second it takes that breath you see
the breath the pressure comes off he's
looking to transition boom there yep
drops it on him as soon as any
relaxation comes in the counter press
came and Mike needs to try to make sure
he doesn't go as far onto the B side
yeah losing position he's been there so
many times with Jerry and I'll tell you
this
Jerry cataract he's unbelievable
committed to trying to get this hammer
one of the chants last year didn't get
it now he's gotten it this year 2019
tied at 1-1 we're in a similar position
to where we were lost very similar
robber to lit so up gonna I've actually
forgotten what it was in terms of time
but it was another ridiculously long
that one was around 4:45 unofficially
Devon Lera taking it in yeah Devon Devon
really wants to shot the winner of this
but I think from a fun perspective
everybody had loved to
see that mushroom because both and we
just heard 450 the official time yes
good job you were awake men because I
forgot I was keeping an eye on it so you
want me we're gonna find out who wants
it most yes yeah be really unangan one
one you can you can hear what it's taken
out Jerry right will be literally
swallow man he's tonged up there yeah
guy sounds like he's just run up the
stairs on his hands yep
so the straps coming out we call the
foul my apologies Jerry this next start
would be seems like he's a little more
relaxed it could be mind games yeah I'd
be exhausted to the same level yeah
before but but but Michael if you look
at him is he breathing hard now
no he's more concerned about the damage
in his hand right but if his power is
still at any kind of level if he can
accelerate in the same way that we know
he has the capability to do he might
just start to pull away a little from
Jerry now because can tourettes feeling
it when he injured the hair
he asked the doctor he said am I going
to risk any permanent damage he said
structurally no you could go with your
nerves last year here we go in the third
book Jerry's trying to close it down
look at the angle even see if he's
really really tired gonna try to go whoa
whoa whoa sweet child away we early all
on each man yeah a very very clear sign
that want to get into the means to get a
little more a sonic though mr. triumph
engaged auto arm a little bit he's
carving out and Jerry trying to get it
all along Michael looks like he's got
plenty left in the time he does
[Applause]
that's how you walk off us Michael shook
an easy buck in there to try and connect
Jerry's timing was he took the pin
nervous times for Michael no we're
scared of science fabulous arm wrestling
look at the face gasps hold there yes
concern on her face in a big way
tremendous match here sherry cataract
one away from winning the hammer yes
indeed you know I'll tell you what
whoever wins this match you gonna say
whether you're a hater or I finally the
round they deserve the win here no doubt
about it
look at that again what happening what
happened in that match there was as
money tried to sit back in and just get
some purchase on Jerry's arm I'm sorry I
thought we may have seen it again there
but if we do see that as he sat in there
he go now watch he's testing and trying
to get restore if see him do it there
yes and it mistimed it boom Jerry
dropped a house on his arm let's look at
it on the replay it looked actually high
was that pin I'm not sure that was a pin
it hit okay we got a contact thought
calling it on the contact Michael not
contesting it it's a pin Bart said it
was right in front of him so he he felt
it oh he's right there right there the
man couldn't be any closer
receiving the ringside seat from God
yep and also what I can tell you there
is that Jerry cut arrest condition going
into that round and still pulled off the
win now that's gonna test your nerves
and Michael will be very aware of that
he he'll be a little angry yeah there
really is I mean a lot of tension if you
if you look at the face on a Rebecca
now March summons them up yeah she's
right away deeply concerned yeah Michael
I think bless so and he just needs to go
to the experience well great much one
reality much sir unreal
absolutely War II cataracts corner there
was Michael Todd here we go now
Jerry cattle rats they drive from Mike
we're going to the straps no surprise no
shocker there that strap has been the
way of things all night and because of
the way that these arm wrestlers contest
the match that's no surprise but what
was a surprise was the fact that Jerry
Connor Rhett was allowed to do able to
do what he did we look at the
unbelievable concern and the face of
Rebecca who said there's no drama at all
right I mean my goodness yeah a little
concern there but Michael isn't he's
pretty calm yeah he's been that's how he
is yeah he's been here before it's Ali's
first rodeo and I be while we're doing
this with me way over here you know it's
it's it's much point in tennis it's that
we've all there all the top guy he's in
the game of being there right your
nerves are jangling a little bit got a
dick this is the test of a champion this
is the test of a champion and you can't
be grow
Jerry cutter rat the success that he has
had in this armwrestling much because he
is leads it to one can win it big
driving it Mike but Mike didn't get
anywhere near the purchase he wanted
there now he's trying to climb little
collections are and we'll see the guys
fall back into that familiar of
armwrestling
both men absolute masters of what they
do under Rebecca you can see Rebecca
there but let's focus on what's going on
not arm-wrestle yes because that's where
the action is and it's what's going on
in their mind that matters most a
Michael Chad now he's trying to connect
and stay on the a side and that's what
he needs to do he needs to initiate he
needs to make sure that he rules the
match a little more rather than allowing
Jerry to make the running because Jerry
Warren back off he's going to keep on
coming and keep on coming Marcus now at
50 seconds in this Paul already had a
four minute and 50 seconds on this
championship tilt Neil big drive from
Jerry there no change
but Michael Tom will be very very
conscious of Jerry's a technology to the
bike
he's driving over there gotta read
smells good in the walls while on the
gingerbread man he's driving hard my
pants off collects his physician must
stay connected to that shoulder and he
will do what's for the press from
monster my quarter he's setting it up
it's coming and it's gonna come horde
Jerry won't be aware of that meal tried
to shut down that light but I'm not sure
he can do so from there but I've been
wrong before
Jerry cataract is a remarkable arm
wrestler this guy is the most underrated
super heavyweight probably ever to do it
and I'll tell you what he is earning all
the pounds and a lot of respect right
here pay the respect to Michael talk
coming up on two minutes now we've
reached it in this Paul Neil an insane
level of endurance shown from these arm
wrestlers Michael Todd and Jerry cutter
it Michael needs to be careful that he
was an expose his shoulder and that
Jerry doesn't jump on him himself
Jerry trying to keep his elbow down and
it's coming up Bart's all over it but
Jerry's got there
maiya taken a foul didn't do collecting
himself Michael's still looking to
transition around if he can find that
leverage point we know what's coming
he'll jump on it and finish the match
Jerry Keller ray is giving no daylight
Snow Hill constant side pressure
constant down
constant commitment I got one elbow on
Jerry often rather that needs to window
just to get the restart yeah there's a
mental battle going on right now
and Michael Tom will not want to let
that happen under any circumstances
right Harry
what do you look for is to make sure
that he lets Jerry know that if it comes
down to that dogfight he's right there
Jerry losing his hand a little and
Michael's that his arm a little better
but his elbow is horribly tucked under
and that doesn't give him the
opportunity to press from anywhere he's
gotta wait and he's got to move Jerry
quite a long way and Jerry is blocking
with his body he's block of the angle
there yeah I'm walking with bow and bow
with sinew with tender fall on him it is
a running foul chariot bucking off then
Larry's right look at him I mean he
wears his mind gone right now Jerry
cutter ret has gone to a very special
place and he could just be
and you can hear the crawling real
microchip trying to get behind his arm
again and engage that shoulder but we
saw big drive from my ass you John that
was a that you fouls restart with the
[ __ ] restart too [ __ ] good
two fouls two files in start know how to
run don't leave the table elbows down
don't leave the table let's go down so
that one ends at five you both did I'm
[ __ ] you want to argue you want to
arm-wrestle let's go an absolute classic
here for the hammer between michael todd
and jerry cataract
I think Micheal Chall has a point there
way that he could have kept his arm down
because Terry there was very clear deal
to to now yeah not that we wanted to see
mate not what Michael wanted to see but
you know what in these circumstances
he'll take it oh my god what it does do
is set up elapsed round so take me take
me I wanted to get to this we got a
little time here you're in um you're in
a match like this yeah take us in that
pit you've been there used to date a
nine-minute pull the longest in your
career what are these guys going through
mentally physically and emotionally
they're going through a situation right
now where all of the textbook stuff you
train hard you grind hard you try to
prepare yourself to arm wrestle in a
service style in a certain technique in
a certain way all of that now is in the
bin it's in the trash counter it's all
gone you can't feel any of those key
parameters you can't feel your heart
your wrist isn't doing what you want it
to do your shoulder isn't performing
your pecs blown out everything that you
utilize to make your game come together
isn't really functioning correctly so
right now you're trying to look at
things analyze things and go through the
motions it's like if a guy's coming back
from a serious injury then they know in
their mind what they are supposed to do
but the body isn't reacting right they
feel like they're running in quick
something the effort is there but
they're unable to make their body do
what it wants to do this is coming down
it's like the Rudyard Kipling poem is if
you
can I've read that yes your heart and
mind and seem you so serve your turn
long they are told me yeah you will be
the man my son none right now as these
men step back to the table this is a
buckle and Will's like we have never
seen ever before and who better to
contest it than these two outstanding
warrants it's going five it's going the
distance books to two we hammer you
don't want then we talk too loudly to
all weekend on the lead up to this
everyone spoken about that one seven
minute much and what that was like yes
the man who walks out of here tonight
with the hammer deserves
it's whether they will mean more than if
they'd wanted rather play all the
circumstantial
here we go Neal push your thumbs close
your hands step you knew that was gonna
happen
yes sir
mr. Michael taught how well you want to
keep that hammer
Jerry calorie how bad do you want that
ha ha
the answer for that question
here we go we'll be found out in the
next few minutes and it will last
forever in the morning everyone who saw
it and it will last a day longer in the
minds of the men that contested that
much huge pivotal moment in the career
of two magnificent armwrestling drama
dripping with drama and passion shown at
the table that a NASA desire of these
arm wrestlers is there for everyone to
see a championship contestant in an ugly
mood old-fashioned but riveting ly
exciting Ben you said it'd be a war and
everyone expected that it's been just
that it comes down to this
- - next pin wins it and where's the
hammer you know it's scary moments on
the stop this Marco's neither man will
react in the way look Michael Maggie's
got hit up over there he was trying to
cause his Hamlet just wouldn't react
Gerry cataract needs to keep dangerous
signs there is macros for that little
check job and he run into a red brick
we're gonna rent this turning his body
supinating the pronation from michael
jordan he's looking for a little rest
spot there trauma this is hip 'some
transition there you'll be a little
nervous about doing that now because he
knows that the last time he did Jerry
jumped on generated equal to it on the
tricep and this guy's in Tucson
Kengo into the mic very very dangerous
times there Michael stays composed but
Gerry smells bloating the water he knows
how close he is to the commoner he can
almost close his hand around it but
Michael Todd reacts and find something
from somewhere digging the color right
now
down with every fiber of his soul to
claim what he believes is his the
heavyweight championship of the world
cause he made the gingerbread man for so
long
could tonight be the night when he
claims it Michael taught trying to
squeak back trying to hold that position
when he finds your sole pulse again
Phoenix Falls there his shoulder done
functioning correctly Jer each other
just get that bum surprised finish use
the momentum you are very close
Michael Saudis in ammonia Michael what's
with a brat incredible position we're
losing the strap the strap is comin off
a real bit there Michael said he'd hold
a break his arm on a faulty main goal
there over two minutes now near
ludicrous position Mike Ross your
purchase now he's lost the strap
connection of his hand and it's hard to
pull from there it is really hard to
pull from there water
unbelievable waffle nucleus tough
decisions
huge commitment Michael chop trying to
hang in there talking to my warplane in
the elbow of Gary Connery was on the
hunt his elbow is very very cool
looks like he's off the bodies on the
money there that looked to me like
Jerry's elbow was on the front of
no pull the referees are right there
that's a now Micheal Chall hanging in
there incredible circumstances
concentrate on the march waggle needs
the winter Bart's gonna look at was
looking for a way out to get the restart
[Music]
you know [ __ ]
Michael Michael Minson take a breath and
calm down here Jerry looking for a way
out there he lifted his elbow purpose to
try and get the restart
[Applause]
you know not kill me - y'all go back and
run back 504 Dave taping lost looking at
it Michael Todd claiming victory replay
the thing to consider here is Jerry
Keller at went on to the foul okay now
once it was called once the foul was
called I then felt that he lost purchase
because he was talking to Bart and then
watch him lift his elbow he lifts his
elbow up in the air lose it there loses
that position
Neal pick up over the video review area
that's a runner
that you've lost that way and I love
this dude I love this dude O'Neal is
over they're winning
Michael Todd continues to claim victory
you can't have one guy in a different
set of rules for somebody else two fouls
on the board on cataract now okay as
they continue to look at it there's Neil
over there with Bart everyone huddle
around over there catching his breath
getting a little wind hoping this thing
isn't over Michael Todd now going over
to talk to Bart I'm injured and Neil you
cannot have one set of rules for Devon
or different world for me I'm not
putting it you get this no [ __ ] way
his elbow came off the pad mine was
still on the pad and he did not put it
back on that is a runner that's three
fouls on you they change it off the same
way Devon layer it in there to the crowd
all right what's dubbed a chocolatey SS
97 million views watched hav lifted
elbows go and lose all right well but I
would not want to be making this
decision right now
I don't mean [ __ ] I would just take the
time to be all sportsmen so the huddle
the conversation continues on in the
fifth pole of the night Michael Todd
feeling that he's wanted on fouls Neal's
making his way back over here to our
broadcast position we certainly get the
word from him and less Bart wood
delivers it before that okay here we go
here's what we have we already had Jerry
on one foul he lifted his arm again two
fouls did not put it back on so he would
get a third foul you didn't make it a
tough to get it back on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you told me just I know I know you find
a proof root I know I know we haven't
always gotta continue to watch I put my
own that I understand that but you can't
look at the film we just did a bunch of
times and I put my elbow back on the
path you lifted it up and did not put
any time to get it back on I did I
pulled it back all right Neil made his
way back over once he gets his headset
back on he'll tell us what went on over
there at the review that's it Michael
Todd retains the hammer I'm very very
disappointed to see that in that way
because that was a wonderful match to
see an end on fouls is bitterly
disappointing to say the least love
these men left it all on the table there
was nothing left from either one the
issue there is that the foul was called
we can't hear what's being said down
there but there's a foul called he then
lifted his elbow up off the pad and
would not put the elbow down the match
was stopped my class the opportunity
there there's not just the rule is clear
you did not put your elbow down it's a
horrible way to lose but you can't run
out of a match it's not possible that
that is a valid point as Jerry said the
strut came undone but unfortunately that
is not in the rules there's nothing you
can do to legislate for the strut
well what an ending a great bed was an
amazing match ride a bull Buffalo and
let's get down to Jason who's with Jerry
cataract Jerry it's hard to even put
into words what just took place here
tonight but you left it all on the table
you had the entire crowd chanting your
name what's going through your mind
right now
shitty would end you know I mean strap
comes undone you can't do [ __ ] you know
so I tried to slip through the straps
because the strap was already out so
definitely definitely a controversial
way to end this season but now you and
Michael are 1 in 1 is this gonna fuel
you moving forward and how yeah I guess
I'll train for the next one everyone
let's give it up one time for Big Daddy
Jerry cataract
[Applause]
that way I don't want to Michael Todd
you just said to Gerry last year you
took on Gerry cataract and he won you
fouled out this year you win as he fouls
out yeah he did good all right so here's
the deal that dudes awesome that dudes
awesome I don't care if you hate me I
don't care if you hate me that match was
a war we were both in this thing for
everything it's worth let me tell you
the problem he had Devin Laird in his
corner Tony's a staff out that's what
happens let your elbow up and get the
foul don't listen to that dude well
Michael it looks like you're you're
finding a lot of rivals here Oh God let
me tell you I don't never won pull that
guy again my hand hurt again it hurt
again the first match I was in perfect
position max you kicked my ass the first
match I didn't like that one the second
match I was in that [ __ ] perfect looked
amazing I'll see that [ __ ] I looked
awesome and then something happened and
I was in a world of trouble didn't like
that either but fortunately I was able
to transition around get the press maybe
felt how do you remember what happened
all I know is I was done as soon as he
didn't put his elbow back down and 97
million people on Facebook watch Dave
Chaffee lose that way I'm taking my
hammer and leaving well a lot of people
are definitely gonna be talking about
this match for some time to come
I was hated before I'm gonna really be
hated now but I'm gonna embrace all that
[ __ ] what's your statement what do you
what do you want to say to the haters
what what do you want to say you and
Rebecca
having a moment celebrating
congratulations you are still on our
champion exactly one second I have the
best wife in the world she just had this
ring made for me
monster Michael Todd armwrestling world
champion
there's the WL hammer there's P al nal
arm wars you a.m. one at all and then
stay in an Arkansas baby alright let's
give it up for the monster Michael Todd
the hammer is stayin in Arkansas
[Applause]